last night I I'm sorry and I saw it this
morning Martin Scorsese was on Jimmy
Kimmel Live Oh was he
yeah oh good for Marty yep and it was a
good interview and it was good you know
Scorsese of course excited about the
Irishman and the fact that he got it
done and everything yep but a certain
scene came up in the interview you want
to see it sure okay
this is Jimmy Kimmel he did like a fool
like I think he did too full segments
and when you get Scorsese on your show I
think you want to keep him on there for
as long as humanly possible they did two
full segments there's a great interview
he was talking about this is the first
time he had met Pacino oh wow that's so
crazy it's so crazy so he was talking
about working with him for the first
time and how like they were supposed to
do this nine years ago when the guys
could actually play younger but because
they were doing other stuff and other
stuff came up they did it now and they
had to really rely on the CGI because
everybody was too old he's talking about
how they had to have like a posture
stand-in because like when Al Pacino
would like get up out of his seat he
didn't look like a 42 year old getting
up out of his seat he looked like a 78
year old getting up out of his seat so
they had to have like people working on
posture and stuff like that and all
complicated but I was very excited at
what would Jimmy obviously a comedian
brought up listen
and while the Ray Romano is great isn't
he terrific in the movie and this guy is
amazing Jim Norton plays Don Rickles and
and that was a great scene and I you
know I knew Don very well and I feel
like if he had seen that he'd be so mad
at you and he would be yes he'd be
furious because he was like why why
that's me what somebody had to get done
in the film and Norton that's the actual
dialogue based on certain sources
certain books that's the actual dialogue
that night of his act he said I make fun
of everyone you know and he says
Italians have not those Italians and
that's when he Joe Eagle pretended to
throw the bottle item don't shoot don't
shoot I've heard him tell that story and
it is exactly as I imagined it it would
be in the film we had to have him in
there yeah okay well you did the right
thing well it's great to have you here
oh great ass ass says he's saying Norton
oh and Norton came in like how amazing
is that
unbelievable holy [ __ ] he knows who you
are
amazing Wow
yeah I didn't hear about that I was
hoping you hadn't I saw it on Twitter
this morning [ __ ] I didn't like text you
about it or anything cause I wanted you
did not see it until just now cuz I went
down right away this morning when I woke
up and like watch the whole interview so
I could see the context and everything
and it was just like that like just at
the end of the thing Jimmy brought up
the scene and and thanks Kimball that's
great yeah I mean I've done a show once
but when I see him we always say hello
like you guys are comics so we all kind
of know each other yeah
he's always been very nice so how great
is that that we go from like wow we go
to the premiere going oh the whole joke
was will you even be in the movie where
you get cop up to now Scorsese is out
doing press for it that's nice and that
scene gets mentioned I made me happy
yeah I thought it would especially when
he goes yeah Norton came in like there
it is that's all you need yeah that
makes so great yeah and it's even better
that it's such a great [ __ ] movie
yeah you saw it right I saw I loved it
I'm glad you did I can't wait till we
can like talk about it because obviously
like not many people can see it right
now yeah I can't even do the the week
spoiler thing because people know it's
not in most theatres no you can't you
gotta wait as long as Jimmy and Marty
like Jimmy and Marty both thought it was
great so Wow
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM